one thing that we were thinking about
when we were talking about friendship it
asked a question to a bunch of the
people who work on this show do you know
why your friends like you what we did is
we interviewed three of Ella's friends
in three different parts of her life and
we asked what do you like about Ella why
do you want to be friends with her
the first person we interviewed was a
new friend of yours ashley crossing from
like calling someone this is my work
friend to my friend friend like that's a
weird thing I think two grown-up thing
that house go on you ready watching yeah
I met Ella about a actually it was
almost two years ago we didn't become
friends until like six months ago you
remember what's your first impression
was oh she's really nice and chill but
kind of quiet which is hilarious to me
now I generally have like a lot of
thoughts and I'm really opinionated and
I don't want people to think I'm a [ __ ]
honestly so I definitely hold myself at
and I remember being like I want to be
friends with Ella but not knowing
exactly how to wait so you had like a
friend crush yeah get a friend crush on
her as well yeah she's awesome
what she's passionate about is so
intense and then the rest of her life is
just so [ __ ] chill people they're
like you're just you're chill you just
have a chill personality and I'm like
cool I'm glad you think that it's
interesting just like watching this now
the thought I just had is the things
that your friends like you for it are
the things that people who don't like
you yeah before it is weird to say like
the thing I don't like about her is that
she doesn't like herself enough
sometimes and it's like dude you're
super cool like just keep proud of that
and be into that's why people like you
thank you yeah it's true I don't know
why I'm so critical of myself but it's
it's awesome to hear that and it just
makes me feel so much better
and so we have another friend of yours
who were gonna watch talk about how she
became friends with you and you guys
went through the experience of college
together what do you think she's gonna
say no college I have no idea
I met Ella through college
we were potluck suitemates
gonna be just like hearing about my life
I knew she was really cool and I wanted
to be friends with her so I'm glad that
we sort of became friends and stuck
together Olive College we continued to
live together until she moved to LA wait
so you saw her on Facebook and you're
like she's cool
yeah yeah I looked through all her
profile pictures and I was like I'm
gonna get along with this girl if you
have a friend crush on me that's so
crazy because I don't think anyone wants
to be friends with me she's definitely
not afraid of people she's not afraid of
being herself or tossing out a really
quickly idea but she's also one of the
most laid-back people that I've ever met
she kind of just rolled out of bed and
she's that cool do you think if you met
today just a DAB are like your faces
like two friends groups sort of like
meeting together and you guys started
talking do you think you would hit it
off
what do you think she's gonna say I
don't know okay see what she says yeah
for sure
yeah okay I don't think sweating
are you ready to watch one of your
oldest friends Julie has known me
through different periods of my life
she's having the longest everything yeah
so it'll be interesting to see if she
has the similar view of me
I met Ella in seventh grade I don't
remember my first impression she was
kind of quiet kind of like the weird
girl in the corner she's a weird girl in
the corner yeah but I kind of was too so
I think that's why we clicked I think
one of my first memories of her is in
school we were playing with large the
large water bottles of course she's
gonna tell this story because I think
about this a lot it's when I smacked her
in the face at the bottle and she
started crying right a water jug exactly
and she ended up smashing me in the face
with one of them so I was like my first
real memory of Ella was me being in pain
of course I remember just being like
well I'm never gonna have friends again
because my new friend is crying now and
she'll hate me forever
what do you like about Ella everything
the first thing that came to my mind is
her impulsiveness she just decides she
wants to do something she doesn't
overthink it and she does it I want to
note that this is I think the third
person who has called you impulsive yeah
I never thought that about myself
what is your friendship look like in 20
years uh we're gonna be friends forever
yeah
whether that's long-distance friendship
like we've done in the past I saw their
friend crush on her yeah
I still want to be her friend
you feel closer to your friends now that
we did this way I feel like I really
know more about myself just from what
they are saying it's amazing to hear
that they really do like me for who I am
and want to be friends with me like that
sometimes you can be insecure I think
but you don't know if people really
still want to be friends with you but
hearing what they're saying about my
personality has been crazy do you think
other people should just ask their
friends why them yeah
yeah I think that's the conversation
people should have it's really
interesting I always push her to work
out more I work out a lot she tricks me
into it she tricks you yeah yeah because
she thinks I'm really unhealthy which I
am isn't see me
No